le monde change chaque changement passe
inévitablement par une phase de
transition dans le domaine de
l'accompagnement individuel changement
et transitions sont deux processus qu'il
faut gérer simultanément le changement
c'est le fait de passer d'un état à un
autre d'une situation à une situation
nouvelle
il est observable par des modifications
externe la transition quant à elle
correspond aux modifications sicot
logique générée par le changement un
changement peut être souhaité construit
subi ou imposé en fonction on ne vivra
pas psychologiquement la même façon d'un
individu à un autre
la phase de transition sera différente
un changement peut nous impacter peu ou
pas il peut se faire sans que l'on s'en
aperçoive un changement peut être vécu
accepté vécu positivement tandis que
d'autres changements nous ébranle nous
déstabilise nous faut résister on peut
passer beaucoup de temps à résister aux
changements à fuir à lutter contre une
situation où à rester là bloqué comme
sidéré ces résistances au changement des
blocages des pertes de repères
une impression de ne plus savoir qu'ils
on est ce que l'on veut où l'on va son
une réorientation psychologique
indispensable induite par le changement
ces résistances s'exprime elle s'exprime
par nos émotions
le deuil le déni la sidération la colère
la culpabilité le doute
les reproches le marchandage la
confusion la tristesse les résistances
s'exprime aussi dans
notre corps par des blocages par des
contractions musculaires par des zones
de tension par des crispations par une
respiration retenu restreinte coupé ou
même des douleurs voire jusqu'à
l'installation possible d'une maladie
vous connaissez peut-être la phrase du
chaos né l'ordre celle ci sous tend que
la phase de résistance pendant la
transition est un mal nécessaire à la
mise en place et à l'acceptation du
changement
c'est un travail de deuil de l'ancienne
situation pour rebondir dans la nouvelle
situation en 2012 je suis face à la
nécessité de mettre en place un
changement important dans ma vie
à 30 ans je suis responsable des
ressources humaines cadres en entreprise
au bureau chaque jour je pleure devant
mon ordinateur j'ai des symptômes
tachycardie vertige essoufflement avec
des bilans médicaux qui sont bons quand
je rentre chez moi je ne fais que dormir
et manger je manifeste un état dépressif
c'est la façon que mon inconscient a
choisi pour se faire entendre
vous savez l'inconscient prend la parole
bien souvent par les maux du corps en
mal de reconnaissance face un sentiment
d'insécurité l'attend par rapport à mon
avenir en totale séparation avec les
gens que j'aime et avec ce que j'aime
faire mon masque de jeunes cadres
dynamiques se fissure et s'effondre il
est temps pour moi de laisser cette vie
au passé et d'en créer une autre
depuis le changement se met en place le
changement me permet de devenir et être
avant ma construction personnelle
reposer sur avoir faire croire être il
suffisait bien souvent de répondre aux
questions qu'est ce que tu veux avoir
pour noël par exemple qu'est ce que tu
veux
obtenir en faisant cela ou qu'est ce que
tu veux faire comme études comme boulot
comme projet c'est ce que j'appellerais
une phase d'oubli de soi pendant cette
phase l'homme développe une grande
capacité
celle de se mentir à lui-même à sa
naissance à notre naissance nous sommes
plutôt relativement pur et innocent en
grandissant rapidement dès le plus jeune
âge on perçoit la reste la réalité de
manière subjective et déformés en
grandissant on perçoit donc la réalité à
travers nos cinq sens des filtres et des
mécanismes en grandissant nous les
renforçons au travers du regard des
autres et à travers toutes les
expériences de la vie
ces filtres sont nos cinq sens
notre culture notre milieu social
notre éducation notre histoire les
traumatismes que l'on a vécu nos
croyances nos valeurs
les peurs les émotions bien d'autres
encore et même un héritage familial
inconscient transpose les mécanismes
sont des erreurs cognitive
d'interprétation d'étiquetage de logique
on a les omissions en effet notre
cerveau ne peut retenir que cette plus
ou moins deux informations
simultanément donc nous opérons un une
sélection à tri des informations qui
nous arrive
ensuite nous avons les généralisations
par exemple à la suite d'une rupture
amoureuse difficile envisager de rester
seul jusqu'à la fin de ses jours
les généralisations permettre d'
exagérées de généraliser à outrance ou
même de n'apporter aucune nuance c'est à
dire de voir les choses en noir ou blanc
et enfin les distorsions les distorsions
c'est ce qui nous permet de déformer la
réalité
ce sont des conclusions hâtives négative
que nous portons des interprétations de
l'attitude de quelqu'un par rapport à
nous
ou alors encore présumé d'erreur de
catastrophes de bien d'autres choses
encore et de coller des étiquettes sur
nous mêmes et sur les autres ces fraudes
qui a écrit en premier sur le mensonge
il a décrit le mensonge par des
mécanismes de protection de l'ego des
stratégies psychologique que nous
mettons en oeuvre pour que l'individu
évite d'avoir accès à des informations
qui pourraient lui faire mal
à partir de ces programmations mentale
de ces schémas psychologique nous nous
identifions à ce que nous avons nous
faisons nos capacités nos comportements
nous nous oublions nous nous concentrons
sur l'extérieur sur l'autre ce qu'il a
ce qu'il fait comment il se comporte
peut-être ce qu'il peut projeter sur moi
alors nous mettons en place des
stratégies des stratégies d'adaptation
de sacrifice de jugement de critiques de
soumission de rébellion dans cette phase
nous luttons nous fuyons nos
comportements nos émotions nos pensées
dépendent de la réalité faussement
perçue mais tout n'est pas noir ou blanc
il ne s'agit pas de s'en vouloir ni de
se juger
toutes ces fuites ces luttes nous
permettent de vivre notre vie à fond
d'engranger des expériences des
souvenirs des retours d'expérience je me
suis enrichi de mes années à la fac de
mes années d'expérience professionnelle
en tant que créateur de mes histoires
d'amour de mes succès de mes échecs mais
après ses succès ses échecs on se
retrouve en
or confronté à soi-même je n'ai pas j'ai
le job que je veux mais je ne suis pas
heureuse je voulais cette promotion
mais c'est intel qui l'a eu j'ai un
compagnon mais je me sens seul je me
sens mal aimés et on se dit des phrases
qui commence par je ne suis pas assez
je ne suis pas à la hauteur je ne suis
pas comme il faut alors pour éviter de
se confronter à cette réalité
pour éviter de devenir honnête avec
soi-même on se ment à nouveau on fait
porter la responsabilité de ses
décisions de ses choix à l'extérieur on
continue à croire l'extérieur on
continue à fonctionner en fonction des
schémas psychologique mentaux par
conséquent on se fait mal et ont fait
mal aux gens qui nous entourent
bien souvent les gens cons qui nous aime
et qu'on aime on fait des choix néfaste
pour soi et pour son entourage
alors est ce que vous vous avez déjà
renoncé à quelque chose d'important dans
votre vie pour vous conformer aux normes
sociales ou pour faire plaisir à
quelqu'un
est ce que vous vous pensez aussi devoir
peser un certain poids gagner un certain
salaire vous marier avoir des enfants
parce que c'est comme ça qu'il faut
faire ou parce que c'est bon pour vous
mais alors me direz vu comment on fait
pour arrêter de se mentir
comment on fait pour reconnaître ces
mensonges et bien déjà on voit qu'on
pointe avec son doigt l'extérieur et
puis se doit on le retourne vers soi
pour regarder la personne à qui
appartient ce doigt pour ma part cela a
commencé en découvrant la pnl la
programmation neuro linguistique qui est
une pédagogie centrée sur la
communication l'apprentissage et le
changement de la personne
cela m'a donné accès à des moyens pour
apprendre à utiliser mon cerveau j'ai
découvert comment j'avais programmé mon
cerveau pour communiquer apprendre
échanger
de ce fait je peux l'utiliser
différemment efficacement et
consciemment je peux reprendre mon
pouvoir personnel pour choisir décider
et agir en toute conscience en 2016
c'est comme une révélation pour moi
d'apprendre tout cela comme un immense
champ des possibles qui s'ouvre devant
moi c'est je ne sais pas si vous
connaissez cette sensation ce oies mais
c'était donc ça puis c'est un élan de
vie un souffle nouveau
un retour vers soi dans cette phase il
s'agit d'explorer sa vie intérieure
donc je commence par observer mes
mensonges à en prendre conscience
à voir comment ils se sont installés et
en quoi ils m'ont été utiles qui m'ont
permis de faire et d'avoir pour ensuite
m'en détacher quand on fait cela on peut
laisser au passé le passé
et celui-ci ne détermine plus qu'ils ont
nés dans le présent il s'agit pendant la
phase de retour à soi de prendre la
responsabilité de son malheur de le
regarder d'amener la conscience dessus
je suis devenu plus honnête plus ouverte
je suis devenu plus responsable de mes
choix présente à moi l'environnement
extérieur est toujours là mais la
conscience est tourné vers son intérieur
pendant la phase d'oubli de soi on a
tendance à juger critiqué blâmer l'autre
pendant la phase de retour à soi on
s'observe on peut se demander quand je
juge l'autre quand je critique l'autre
qu'est ce que ça veut dire deux mois le
retour à soi c'est cessé de fuir et de
lutte et le retour à soi c'est voir que
l'on a cherché des solutions à
l'extérieur
j'ai longtemps attendu une intervention
divine tombé du ciel dans ma vie une
bonne étoile
un sauveur quelqu'un qui viendrait me
sauver beaucoup croient encore un monde
politique providentiel qui viendrait les
sauver croire en des solutions
extérieures ne sert possiblement à rien
peut-être parfois seulement à nous
ramener vers soi le retour à soi c'est
aussi se défaire de l'ignorance de ces
avis de ses opinions de ses croyances de
ses émotions de ses conflits intérieurs
c'est le grand détachement pour pouvoir
laisser exprimer qu'ils on est vraiment
dans le monde
c'est l'expression du soin en effet
pendant la phase de retour à soi pendant
qu'on se concentre sur son intérieur le
monde autour continue de tourner et il
est indispensable de rester au contact
du monde parce que tout se fait
en son coeur au sein même du monde
depuis mon plus jeune âge et encore
aujourd'hui tous les jours j'ai eu la
chance de rencontrer les chevaux c'est
grâce à eux que je suis resté au contact
du monde
sans eux il aurait été facile de me
replier sur moi même et de fuir encore
une fois car le monde peut apparaître
comme un obstacle mais en réalité il est
le révélateur c'est grâce à lui
grâce aux circonstances de vie grâce aux
rencontres grâce au quotidien que va se
révéler ce qu'il y a en soi
j'ai découvert que si j'imagine que le
monde est indemne
un ennemi il le sera et nous serons en
lutte
par contre si je fais face à ma vérité
de ce que je suis où que je sois je peux
m'exprimer et réaliser ma vraie nature
dans le monde
je peux désormais endosser les rôles
choisi entrepreneurs coach en équitation
cavalière soigneuse d'équidés avec
responsabilité et en exprimant ce que je
suis c'est la liberté la liberté d'être
la liberté de réaliser sa vraie nature
de réaliser sa raison d'être car vous
savez la vie n'a de sens qu'à partir de
l'instant où on lui en donne on peut
alors exprimé sa vérité celle qui donne
de l'énergie des potentiels des
capacités des capacités qu'on n'avait
pas auparavant
j'ai développé des capacités de
discernement de patience de sagesse de
lâcher prise de résilience d'acceptation
bien plus que je les avais auparavant
tout ceci est un processus un processus
progressif non linéaire il ya des hauts
des bas il y à des avancées et des
retours en arrière
processus jeu l'expérimentent
quotidiennement dans des domaines sur
certains sujets j'exprime ma vérité à
d'autres endroits
je me mens encore dans ces cas là qu'est
ce que je fais je m'arrête je m'observe
je me demande qu'est ce que ça dit de
moi je prends conscience je décide
d'arrêter de me mentir gym et de ma
vérité à la place que je peux exprimer
je peux agir je peux agir en étant qui
je suis vraiment je peux être
c'est le retour à l'équilibré intérieur
on appelle l'écologie intérieure dans un
système où l'être humain prend pas tout
peut commencer par l'écologie intérieur
le changement commence individuellement
car si nous faisons en sorte d'arrêter
le fait que le système change
l'être humain que nous sommes nous
pouvons reprendre notre pouvoir
personnel et nous pouvons nous changer
nous-mêmes et changer le monde autour la
science des systèmes la systémique pose
comme principe que tout système est un
sous système dans un système plus vaste
l'être humain dans son monde dans le
monde et que système et sous systèmes
sont en interrelation constante alors
pour finir je peux que vous encourager
et vous dire soyez vrai et exprimer
votre vérité dans le monde
[Applaudissements]